haha welcome to this video playing the
cycle cowboy Simon Williams yeah he
recently gained some ground on me I
really have to say i want the first
games all of them and now I lost a
couple so let's see playing some kind of
anti Dutch probably probably he knows
every line under the Sun against against
the Dutch okay pushes the a porn early
on okay okay cannot go a three and this
position so I'm not quite sure what it
does I mean okay i see that i cannot
move my knight but it's not it's not a
necessity at the moment okay we it still
looks a little bit like is like his
favorite classical dutch 9283 bishop see
394 doing that i really don't have a
hard time to understand that opening I
really have to say not bad in a bad way
just that I don't understand I don't
understand it many many ideas and things
that happen ok now it's a transposition
on transformation let's say it's not
like I'm in no one particular position
but we got into something that very much
looks like the stone wall 94 maybe hmm
yeah I don't know if I can move the
bishop to some decent place so he might
as well take it okay let's put this here
maybe I can put the bishop somewhere
else before or something yeah let's not
be too sophisticated here try to not
take so long knight c6 is system it
looks problematic actually I'm him this
looks bad or can he go 95 let's start
with that the capture be sure before
Nancy five is just a self and i can move
the night back and then he's in this pin
so he probably has to go has to go there
and now i have 95 I think and check g5
at the end hmm not totally sure I forgot
about that move who takes with the
bishop he does ah now I didn't think
about that really didn't take take I
have Quincy six though d5 and Lucas
hanging
I didn't see that before I just sheer
luck that this is this is that this is
available rook g5 look THX quite quite a
problem check quite a problem here
resins yeah it was a very lucky game
actually because I didn't see I didn't
see many of his moves um maybe it was
was okay but I didn't really okay i
don't i don't know about b6 allowing
knight c6 looks a bit strange but i'm
not sure not sure really I'm very okay
here i took TIG TIG so it looks ok here
now I went 95 I really you know what I
totally did not consider what the bishop
captured I was thinking that I am it
would be like that that was what I was
seeing but this is a nonsense line what
we got is actually completely winning
for me I mean it takes and he cannot
take now yeah this is this is just just
winning Queen c6 here rook g5 are
threatening rook the eighth winning and
it's it's gone it's simply gone he has
no move Queenie eight yeah thats its
also check come on with my mouth check
and that's it yeah he's in a deadly
deadly pinned I mean he's mature down
and in a pin so it's a bit it's a bit
much yeah I didn't really see how good
this was but okay if you underestimate
your your current position it's not a
big problem usually cool thanks for
watching